I thank you much very much for to the
organizers for inviting me of course and
I changed the topic of my top because
today is polynomial day so I thought it
very fitting that I talk about my work
with polynomials especially polynomials
having to do with NP complete problems
so off we go here is a big picture
overview of where we're going we start
out with some combinatorial problem one
that we know and love like graphic a
color ability partition perfect matching
independent set and off we go we model
it as a system of polynomial equations
and once we are there with that
algebraic representation there are a
couple of things that we can do the
system of polynomial equations of course
will either be feasible or infeasible
the underlying combinatorial property
will either be satisfied or not
satisfied and so if it is satisfied we
can look at the grosvenor basis and we
can look at the algebraic representation
of that grosvenor basis and investigate
whether it's polynomial size or
exponential size and also what is the
combinatorial interpretation of those
polynomials similarly if it's infeasible
if the underlying combinatorial property
has no solution we can look at gilberts
new Stalin sought certificates of
infeasibility so there we are and in
both cases we can investigate we can run
computational experiments and we can
investigate so off we go let's look at a
problem that we know and love the
independent set problem given a graph G
we ask the question does there exist a
subset of vertices of size K such that
no two vertices are adjacent so we are
very familiar with this and here we can
see a sample graph that will be working
with and we can observe that vertices
three and four are an independent set
and we can further observe using our
finely-honed skills that the largest
independent set in this graph is of size
2 and the Greek letter associated with
that is alpha G and that will be used
later so off we go we said that our
overall structure
was to take this combinatorial problem
and model it as a system of polynomial
equations so again this is something
that we know and love this is lovas as
representation of the independent set
problem as a system of polynomial
equations so no problem at all one
variable per vertex for every vertex we
have this polynomial which says
basically the vertex is either one or
zero the vertex is either in the
independent set or not and then for
every edge we have this certifying that
no two adjacent edges can both be in an
independent set and since we want an
independent set of size K we then can
sum up all the vertices and say we want
exactly K vertices to be in the
independent set so now we have a system
of polynomial equations of course it's
satisfied if and only if the underlying
graph has an independent set of size K
so here we are here's our trusty example
and here's the system of polynomial
equations associated with the question
of does this graph have an independent
set of size three and of course the
answer's no so in this case we get to
investigate the Gilberts no stones on
certificate of infeasibility and you can
see here are the vertex polynomials here
are the polynomials associated with the
edges and here we have the question of
is there an independent set of size
three so off we go and let's refresh our
memory as to exactly what hilbert's new
stalin's offsets so from 1893 a trusty
theorem that we still use today given a
system of polynomial equations f1
through FS this system has no solution
if and only if there exists polynomials
beta 1 through beta s such that the
number one can be expressed as a
combination of those beta polynomials
and those f polynomials so if we have
this algebraic identity if it happens
that we stumble across it if this
algebraic identity exists we can be
certain that the underlying system of
polynomial equations has no solution
because if there was a solution if
there was some point where all of these
polynomials simultaneously whoops
madness all of those polynomials
simultaneously equaled 0 then what we
would end up with is 1 equal to 0 which
of course can't happen so if we have
this then no such solution exists so
this is a certificate of in feasibility
this is a mini proof if they have we
have this nothing more is needed so
here's an example here's a trustee
system of polynomial equations very
simple and if I choose to put these
particular coefficients on those
polynomials if I expanded them out and
group the coefficients together you
would very easily see that everything
cancels out to zero except the constant
term which is one so no problem at all
this is indeed a new Stella not
certificate of infeasibility so off we
go we call this in your stones out
certificate and we want to measure the
complexity so we measure the complexity
by the things that are missing of course
we have this this is given to us as
input so we're interested in what we
don't have so we say that D is the
maximum degree of those missing
coefficients that's the degree of the
new shell and soft certificate so off we
go of course it's useful to take just
one second to say how we find those so
let's look here's a sample system what
we would do is guess the degree and
create general coefficients of that
degree with unknowns associated with the
variables then we expand everything out
we group the lope the like coefficients
together and what we then see is that
these are linear expressions so these
have to sum to zero except the constant
term which has to be one this gives us a
system of linear equations which we are
then more than capable of solving so if
we are lucky and if we have guessed
right that this happened to be the
degree if we guessed right we could then
reconstruct the certificate otherwise we
have to increment the degree in repeat
so that's just a short word about how we
find the certificate
we won't really talk more about that
we're interested in what the
certificates look like so the complexity
of finding a certificate compared with
the complexity of just determining
straight out and there's a solution it's
going to there's going to be a mapping
they're absolutely since the independent
set problem is np-complete we would
expect the size of the linear system to
be exponential so that it was not a
polynomial time algorithm we would
expect the degree to be high if it is an
np-complete problem we would expect the
degree to be low if it was a problem NP
problem that I mean but there's also is
only like a one sided answer right
you're assuming it's insulting yes
exactly I mean if it happens that the
problem does have an independent set of
size K then you would have to iterate
awfully high in order to really
determine that no such new Stellan
thought certificate exists there are
well known upper bounds for the size of
new stones on certificates so the
algorithm will terminate but obviously
you would be better posed to look for
the grosvenor basis kind of alternate a
little bit guess a degrees see if it
works maybe try the grosvenor basis that
kind of thing switch back and forth but
what we are interested in is taking a
look at what the certificates look like
what is the combinatorial interpretation
of these certificates so here is our
trusty example and here is the
polynomial which determines the size of
the independent set and you can see here
I've decided to jump it to four just
because I feel like it but the important
relevant thing is so here's this
polynomial here the edge polynomials and
here are the vertex polynomials here and
this algebraic identity does indeed sum
to one if you put into maple or did it
out by hand but what's interesting is
this what we see over here so what we
see over here is that there's one
monomial for each of the vertices one
monomial for the single isolated
independent
sets and then there's one monomial for
one and two and three and four
indicating that these are indeed
independent sets so what you can see by
looking at this certificate is that the
degree of the certificate is equivalent
to the size of the largest independent
set and that there's one monomial for
each of the independent sets so what we
see here in the new Stalin's death
certificate is the full count of all the
independent sets and we have a theorem
of course which says that so the degree
is equal to alpha G which is our
independence number and it contains at
least one term for every independent set
so off we go investigating so what is
there more to say about the certificate
we've discussed and presented an
interpretation of those monomials in
full but now we want to investigate
these numbers what do these numbers mean
is there something combinatorial to be
said about these numbers so we can see
that we can answer that question really
beautifully if we go to a different NP
complete problem that we know and love
and this one is the partition problem
given a set of integers can you split it
into two such such that they sum to the
identical number and off we go here's an
example we have a set of numbers and
we're going to split them into two
pieces certainly if I wish this could be
asked certainly if I wish this could be
everything else a quick addition yields
the fact that this is indeed partition
abul fine so we comment that this is an
np-complete yes quite right we allow
repetitions here yes yes ah so off we go
investigating very easy to see this
represented as a system of polynomial
equations there is similar to what we
had before one variable / integer and
now one polynomial again / integer X I
squared minus 1 X I of course will be
plus or minus 1 indicating one side of
the partition or the other side of the
partition in the same way that the
independent set meant in
the independent set or not in the
independent set so off we go and then of
course we want these two sum to zero
because we want the partitions to
balance so nice and easy of course this
comes with a nice little proposition
this system of polynomial equations is
satisfied if and only if there exists
some partition so here we go here we
have a system of polynomial equations
and we ask the question is this
partition abul and you can see that here
we have 1 3 5 and 2 this polynomial here
maps to this polynomial here these
polynomials here determine which side of
the partition the integers on so with a
quick inspection we can convince
ourselves that this is indeed not
partition about just a quick inspection
so we expect this to be infeasible we
expect a hill there's your stones out
certificate to exist so off we go
looking for it and there it is just a
nice healthy disaster with much more
complicated numbers so first let us look
and see what we can glean about the
monomials so here is x1 squared minus 1
and a quick inspection yields that this
has even degree monomials and none of
the monomials contain X 1 similarly here
x2 this has even degree monomials
nothing containing X 2 similarly here so
what we begin to see is that these
monomials are a brute force iteration
over all the partitions this new still
and sought certificate is counting all
of the partitions now and of course we
were able to prove that we have a nice
theorem very large and cumbersome but
basically this says that this minimum
degree certificate contains exactly one
monomial for each of the even parity
subsets and exactly one monomial for
each of the odd parity subsets fine very
similar to what we saw for the
independent set but what about those
numbers that's what we were after
next so off we go and I'm going to hone
in on them of course our diverse oh yes
it's it yeah up take your time it's yeah
take your time
what do you mean by dense ah by dense so
the notion is what you have here is a
certificate of the non-existence of a
combinatorial property so we expect that
proof to be hard to verify because we
don't expect NP 2 equal co MP so by
dense I basically mean dense with
monomial monomials you could have a
certificate that was of high degree but
it was very sparse and so therefore
still easy to verify but because this is
high degree and very dense with
monomials it's it takes exponential time
to verify as well as calculate many
monomials that's right many monomials
yes exactly okay so now we'll breeze on
and we'll just take another look and now
you can see the theorem reflected here
are the even degree sets these are all
the even degree sets and now here you
see the odd degree sets degree 1 and 3
degrees 0 and 2 so here in the
certificate we see the theorem expressed
so now as promised we're after this
number what's the combinatorial
interpretation of this number how do we
see the counting of the independent sets
reflected in this number so off we go it
turns out that we can take the
underlying linear system associated with
these certificates we can massage them a
little bit and make them square so now
here I have a matrix which I call the
partition matrix and this matrix comes
from that linear system fine now if I
wish I could regale you with a
brute-force iteration over every
possible partition so I'm going to do
that so here are our numbers w1 w2 and
w3 and I stick w 3 on one side of the
partition I can put both on one I can
put one on one one on the other I can do
flip them about and then i can put both
on the other side very entertaining
brute force iteration so if i wished i
could put signs upon them whoops if i
wished i could put
upon them nothing certainly stopping me
from doing that the positive versus the
negative if I wished I could then
multiply all of those things together no
reason why I can't I can then give it a
name but the interesting thing finally
arrives for us the determinant of this
matrix is now equal to this partition
polynomial the determinant of this
matrix happens to be to factor as the
brute force iteration over every
possible partition so was that fluke we
asked ourselves so off we went we
investigated one larger this again comes
specifically from the linear system we
can take the determinant and factor it
and again we see a brute force iteration
over every possible partition so that
was the theorem that came out of this a
schmoo on your colleague I believe and
now we will take a look by Cramer's rule
week basically you take the Hilbert's
new shell and sought certificate
associated with the degree for that
particular set of integers and you
perform some very simple manipulations
and some of the equations drop out and
it goes down to a square matrix yeah
just some massaging going from a non
square linear system to a square linear
system so by Cramer's rule nice and easy
here is our number 34 / 693 and what we
see is here is the brute force iteration
over every possible partition for these
particular numbers and we apply Cramer's
rule and this is what we get and that is
indeed the 34 / 693 so each one of the
numbers in that new stones that
certificate represents comes from the
counting of all of the possible
partitions so off we go investigating
more because some these were very nice
these combinatorial interpretations were
very clean and very pretty but that
doesn't always
it doesn't always work out that way so
given a graph G in an integer cake and
the vertices be colored with K colors in
such a way that no two adjacent vertices
are the same color and no problem at all
here's our trusty Peterson graph three
colorable as we know and love so now we
want to represent this as a system of
polynomial equations so we're going to
use a field K such that the
characteristic a is relatively prime to
the coloring number yes no students of
the coefficient speak I think you're
holding ever certain degree so can you
back it give the degrees of
combinatorial interpretation ah you mean
for the partition problem yes so the
partition problem should behave
differently from independent set problem
I mean yes as a difficult problem as the
independence yes absolutely so um I if
you cast your mind back it was a 14 you
had one monomial for every even degree
set and one monomial for every odd set
so that means that the degree is going
to be n minus 1 if it's even and an if
it's odd so in the case of the
independent set problem the degree of
the certificate was alpha G the size of
the largest independent set in the case
of the partition it'll be N or n minus 1
depending on the parody of n because
you're doing an iteration over every
possible set so so just going back to
see that here for example n is 4 we have
four integers so the degree here is
degree 3 and minus 1 is the size of the
largest even degree set and that will be
true so if this was odd so now the
degree here is n minus 1 this is the
degree 3 is the largest coefficient if n
was odd the degree here would be n it
would go all the way up to 5
okay so off we go a que color ability
now so here we have the encoding we have
one variable per vertex just as before
we allow K colors so k roots of unity
and no problem we're going to call this
polynomial V I this will come into play
will use this in a second when we
explore a groebner basis and here we
have for every edge now this polynomial
here it's easy enough to see that this
polynomial here forces every vertex to
take on one of the K roots of unity or
one of the K colors but this polynomial
here causes each of the vertices to take
on a different color and that's easy
easier to see when you realize that this
polynomial factors thusly and so will
call that EU of IJ and as before this
comes with a trustee theorem saying this
is feasible if and only if the graph is
K colorable so off we go investigating
and here's our trusty Peterson graph
this is indeed three colorable and here
you can see for every vertex in the
graph it is one of the three colors and
here we see for every edge in the graph
this this here forces each of those
adjacent vertices to share a different
color so this problem is feasible so
just for fun in a very simple case we'll
look at the grosvenor basis and we'll
see if the complexity of the grosvenor
basis can mirror some of the complexity
of the combinatorial problem so we look
and we refresh our memory and we say a
graph is Cordle if every cycle of length
greater than 3 has a court ie every
induced cycle has length at most 3 so
over here on our left we see a graph
with a lovely set of induced cycles this
graph is Cordle and over here we see a
cycle and induced cycle of length for
that has no cord so this graph is Cordle
this graph is
so off we go and we have a theorem that
says if the graph happens to be Cordle
then there exists a polynomial time
computable groebner basis for the cake
coloring ideal and this doesn't surprise
us because of course chordal graphs are
going to be very easy to grapple with so
we expect easy complexity in the
combinatorial problem to be reflected
within the algebraic geometry and I just
comment that this theorem has a healthy
number of authors on it it came out of
one of the mrcs that's no bird Utah so
let's take a look just visually let's
investigate what happens with this proof
so we have a particular polynomial which
we named SR and here is a graph and we
comment that it's well known that every
chordal graph can be iteratively
constructive constructed and we're going
to use that well-known iterative
construction to build a grosvenor basis
and that's kind of how the proof went so
we take a look and if we wanted to
iteratively construct this particular
chordal graph we could start with vertex
one and this associated polynomial
remember that would just be X I to the K
minus 1 or X 1 to the K minus 1 and as
we add an edge we add this particular
polynomial as we add another edge we add
this particular polynomial as we
continue growing it we add the
Associated polynomial and by the time we
get to the end we have the chordal graph
and this is the grosvenor basis it turns
out so that was the theorem that came
out of snow bird so now we've looked at
grosvenor basis now let's look at the
hilbert new stolen Sox certificates so
we actually don't know very much about
these certificates surprisingly enough
for the partition problem for
independent set the counting to the
algebraic geometry is clear it's nice
and clean nice and clear for graph k
color ability even for graph three color
ability it is
a mystery so we know that the degree
grows in this nice clean pattern this
doesn't bother us 147 10 in the case of
three color ability this makes sense to
us and degree 1 certificates have been
explored there is a known combinatorial
interpretation of just degree 1
certificates and it was done twice one
at delaware a-- hillier malkin and omar
in 2010 they described a covering of the
graph in terms of directed edges and
they said if the graph had a particular
covering of these directed edges then it
had a degree one certificate and its
non-color ability could be solved in
polynomial time so this was a new piece
of combinatorics coming out of the
algebraic geometry in 2015 this was
tightened a bit and the direction the
directed edges were dropped and Lee
Lowenstein and Omar came up with a
interpretation just based on two paths
so a two paths cover if your graph had a
particular to path cover it was a
polynomial-time solvable instance of
graph three coloring which was again new
now what about degree for certificates
the next most simple number but it turns
out that this remains an open question
the combinatorics here is is not yet
understood so we do know however that
there is a family of graphs that follows
this pattern it's the mushy haro mushy
harem mizuno infinite family of graphs
and basically what they do is they start
out with a series of graphs basically
they take all these graphs and they
throw them in a bag and these are called
mugs minimum unsolvable graphs mugs and
then they reach into the bag and they
take two of them and then they pick a
vertex at random and join those two
graphs using something the oyo scan the
oil construction so that's how they
create an infinite family and it turns
out that if you
you apply that algorithm and you create
an infinite family of graphs so here
we've done that g0 we say g1 g2 g3 g4
ten vertices 18 edges 20 vertices 37
edges 3055 3972 4990 so we've
constructed a little bit of this
infinite family and nicely enough the
degree starts at one then it stays at
four for a little while and then it
changes it mind and it goes to degree
seven so here we see that pattern but
the combinatorics what it's counting
what is it trapping what the algebraic
geometry is counting is not so clear so
off we go investigating are you saying
those numbers are independent of which
you're saying it's not there's not a
unique one in each degree or there is a
unique one in each degree hmm a unique
one of what this is this infinite family
of graphs which is constructed randomly
so this is just a particular a
particular thing are those degrees
Independence of the random construction
of a based on a particular construction
okay a good question the answer is I
actually don't know I can tell you that
this particular series of graphs which
we constructed you you know by choosing
a particular random vertex happen to
work out this way but as to whether the
second graph you know is the first each
and every one of these has degree one
that I can assure you but does every end
choose to combination go to degree for
that I'm not sure of and every time you
add an extra graph does it stay for does
it stay for again and then does it
always change to seven that I can't be
yeah yeah but it is rather delightful to
at least have an example to work from
something to look at where we could try
to count an experiment so off we go
we've looked now at
variety of NP complete problems why not
look at problems that are NP with the
exception of course of the chordal
graphs that was a problem in P so we
asked given a particular combinatorial
problem does there exist some encoding
such that the new Stellan thought
certificates have polynomial size if the
problem is in p will we have an easy
algebraic proof so off we go the
Petersons graph is 3 colorable as we
know very easy to say it's not too
colorable no problem at all we all know
that if a graph is not too colorable it
contains an odd cycle and it won't
bother us at all to realize that we can
take that odd cycle and go directly to a
new Stellan thought certificate of non
to color ability a problem in p2 very
simple algebraic geometry and we can see
it here so here is the vertex zero and
we can see nice and easy we can trot
around the outside a nice odd cycle
right so we start with we remind
ourselves that for not to color ability
we have two possible colors and here
would be the associated edge polynomial
so we start with vertex zero we walk
along we add the polynomial associated
with this edge then we add the
polynomial associated with the next step
and we continue to trot around that odd
cycle adding and alternating our signs
as we go and it won't bother us to see
that in the end this is indeed a new so
ends up certificate so from the odd
cycle comes nice and clean algebraic
geometry a problem in P has a nice small
certificate ah now what about perfect
matching what about one of our favorite
problems our most favorite combinatorial
problems so I here we have a graph I it
has a perfect matching no problem at all
we want to represent this as a system of
polynomial equations so every vertex for
every vertex I we take all the
neighborhoods we want only to be
incident on one matched edge for every
adjacent
edge only one of them can be matched no
problem at all and here we have a graph
which has an odd number of vertices no
perfect matching of course why do I even
bother to show you such a simple thing
here is the now notice I'm taking this
over the complex numbers at first and
here's the certificate a horrible
disaster not clean at all for a problem
supposedly in p but when we change the
field from the complex numbers when we
change it to f2 this complicated
certificate does indeed simplify very
nicely and that is a friendly we would
expect that very borin a graph G has an
odd number of vertices of course there's
no perfect matching there is a degree
zero in your stones that certificate
this doesn't bother us at all nice and
clean we would expect that but what
about even number of vertices it's
equally simple problem it's equally
known to be solvable in polynomial time
what happens then unfortunately the
graph the degree of the new stones out
certificate grows for the perfect
matching problem even over a small
finite field which bothers us to no end
so refresh your memory as to touch
theorem a perfect matching if anomia for
every subset you the subcraft induced
has at most you connected components
with an odd number of vertices so we can
very easily build an infinite family of
graphs around a set you that we can
remove leaving a series of odd
components this is the most simple
infinite family of graphs with an even
number of vertices that has no perfect
matching and alas the degrees of those
grow starts out at one grows too too
gross to three up to four not polynomial
size this is extremely annoying to us so
we leave the open question is there
there are two ways to pursue this is
there an encoding that is cleaner or a
finite field that works better such that
this nice problem solvable in polynomial
time has a nice clean series of
algebraic identities or
is it possible to take these
certificates and reduce them via some
quotient ring so we're looking at both
of those things because we're determined
that a problem in peace should have a
come a nice compact algebraic
representation so those are some open
problems all these results were taken
from the following papers with the
including this one this is the one to
come out of snow bird all available on
my website of course and thank you very
much for your kind attention time for
some questions I wonder if you ever
consider imagining bipartite graphs it's
not so difficult yes we I it does it
does grow it does grow it's very
annoying it's very annoying yes so we're
looking trying to understand what
combinatorics gets picked up that's not
so good and how could we maybe reduce it
very interesting I mean as we know it's
polynomial time it would be very
interesting to say for this particular
system of linear equations this equation
you so mean yeah I this this was a
surprising result this was a very
annoying result this result did not
these experiments i should say did not
does not correspond to our intuition so
we're working on improving one of the
two either our intuition or they just I
mean you experimentally verified yes not
proved if it was proved probably we
would have much greater insight yeah an
open problem still yes sir
counting security is shorty art how does
this reflect Center but the equations
are very special occasions they are not
like an np-hard in terms of the roof
explain what do you know anything so it
is what you say is very interesting so
of course counting the number of
partitions counting the number of
independent sets also Sharpie heart and
of course what we see in the new shells
out certificate is a clear one-to-one
matching of that difficulty but it turns
out that the combi the Turks that gets
picked up in the certificates of non
three-color ability is not so clear it's
not so clear what it's counting it
doesn't it's it's not counting the
number of colorings it's for example in
the degree one case it's not counting
the number of colorings at all it's
counting the number of this particular
covering which was a combinatorial
property that was not known before
people started studying the certificates
directly which is just interesting so
there's hope perhaps of well there must
be there must be a combinatorial
property to describe the degree for
certificates which will then indicate
another polynomial-time solvable class
of non three colorable graphs so does
the certificates coming out of the by
Parker cases does it like at monomials
iterating over all perfect matchings
sorry those aren't third invasion cases
not so clear not so clear yeah it's it's
not so clear yeah I am not sure what is
happening yet but it's it does not seem
to be a brute force iteration over the
perfect matchings yeah
that even that or even largest matching
the smallest linear programming
extension is still exponentially large
and I think even the semi definite
program and out if it was a hierarchy
and so on blossom come out piece of
house is connected with the searches
birth certificate series that is there a
connection between there so you're quite
right you've stated it very clearly
there's a hierarchy having to do with
the lizard bound with semi definite
programs certainly with the matching we
have a sequence of linear algebra
computations so in the same way we have
a series of semi definite programs we
have a series of linear algebra
sequences it the relationship between
the two is not known it's it's certainly
I'm aware of the results that you say it
is very interesting that the the
smallest linear algebra representation
is exponential size certainly this
representation is nice and clean
polynomial size no problem at all we
have one polynomial per vertex one
polynomial / edge definitely we have a
compact representation but not a compact
new cell and sought certificates so
maybe a proof between those mapping
those two areas is something to look
into but not knowing
ok